in this video we're going to review what
we've already learned about monopsony
employers that we've covered in
a previous video but then we're going to
add a twist of adding a minimum wage and
see what happens and it's actually
interesting it's actually somewhat
counter-intuitive
so just as a bit of a review when we're
talking about a monopoly generally we're
talking about one buyer and
many
many sellers so when we're talking about
a monopsony employer that one buyer is
the one employer that might be say in a
small town and they're the big industry
there and they're the only person that a
lot of folks could work for and then the
many sellers well those are all of the
workers the people who are selling their
labor and we've already talked about
the rational quantity of labor that that
monopsony employer would hire
so you have your wage
in on that axis that's in dollars you
have your quantity
of labor
on the horizontal axis we can think
about our downward sloping marginal
revenue product of labor every
incremental unit of labor you might get
a little bit lower and lower
marginal
revenue from that
from that input so this is our marginal
revenue product mrp we could call it
marginal revenue product of labor
because you could also have marginal
revenue product of capital or of land
other factors of production but we're
talking about employment here
and then we could think about the
marginal factor cost now this is a
significant difference between a
monopsony employer and an employer in a
perfectly competitive labor market if we
were dealing with a perfectly
competitive labor market then the
employer would just have to pay the
market wage and so the marginal factor
cost the amount that they would have to
pay for an incremental unit of labor
will just be a constant
constant whatever the market wage of
labor is so that would be the marginal
factor cost and it would be rational if
if this was not a monops in the employer
to just keep hiring more and more as
long as the marginal revenue product is
higher than the marginal this flat
marginal factor cost curve which is set
by the market wage rate so it would
produce or it would higher i should say
this quantity of labor but for a
monopsony employer you could view them
as in a lot of ways they are the late
the labor market is
is is they are the only buyer in the
labor market and so we could think about
a supply curve of labor just for their
market or just for their industry or
just for them really
and so it could look something like this
so this is the supply of labor supply
supply
of
labor
and we've talked about that this is not
the marginal factor cost curve for the
monopoly employer because even though
that first person might be willing to
work for this wage and then the very
next unit of labor might be willing to
work for a slightly higher wage if you
have to give that slightly higher wage
to the second person we assume that
whatever wage they give to one person
they have to give to everyone in this
video we're going to review what we know
about a monopsony
employer and then we're going to add a
twist that deals with minimum wages
which are going to be it's going to be a
little bit counter-intuitive so just as
a review a monopsony in general is when
you have one buyer and many sellers
and a monopsony employer is the
situation where that one buyer they're
the buyer of labor of that factor of
production and so you have one employer
and then the many sellers these are the
sellers of labor the people who are
providing their own labor so these are
all of the workers and we've already
studied this in previous videos but i
will review it right now
we can draw our classic axes where you
have your wage rate here in dollars on
the vertical axis
you have your quantity of labor right
there in the horizontal axis we can
think about our marginal revenue product
of labor curve so every incremental unit
of labor the firm gets a little bit less
benefit in in ter measured by revenue
so less and less and less revenue and so
this is marginal revenue product this is
marginal revenue product of labor
because we're talking about labor
markets if this was another factor of
production it would be marginal revenue
product of capital or of land or
whatever else and then we could think
about the marginal factor cost if this
were not a monops in the employer
whether the marginal factor cost would
just be the market wage rate so it would
look something like that
and we've already seen this if this was
an employer in a perfectly competitive
labor market but this is not an employer
in a perfectly competitive labor market
they're the only employer in this small
town they're the big industry and so
they're going to have their own unique
labor supply curve so it might look
something like this
labor
i'll just write it supply of labor
supply
of labor
and you might be tempted and we thought
about this in a previous video to say
hey this is going to be the marginal
factor
marginal factor cost curve of labor
because you say well you know that first
person is willing to work for that much
the second person is willing to work for
that much or the second unit of labor
but remember we said or we're making the
assumption that even a monopsony
employer if it pays if it has to raise
the wage to get that second unit of
labor it has to raise the wage for
everyone so when it when it goes further
and further up the supply curve as it
hires more and more and more it's not
just paying the incremental amount to
that incremental person it has to pay to
everyone so it's marginal factor cost is
going to go up twice as fast so the
marginal factor cost curve is going to
look something like this
so it's going to look like this
our marginal factor cost curve and this
is of course when we're dealing with a
monopsony employer and so what is the
rational quantity of labor for this firm
to hire
well it's going to keep hiring as long
as on on the margin every incremental
unit of labor it brings on it gets more
revenue than it has to incur in cost so
as long as the marginal revenue product
is higher than the marginal factor cost
it keeps hiring all the way until this
point when they're equal so it would
higher
it would higher this quantity of labor
and what is the wage it would have to
pay
sometimes we just instinctively go back
to this dot we just want to go
horizontally because we're thinking
about thinking about equilibrium prices
and quantities but remember this at this
quantity this is not the wage up here
the wage is defined by the supply curve
and so this is the wage that the firm
would pay
now i'm going to add a twist
what do you think would happen if this
town said all right well this employer
has too much power here and we think
they should pay higher wages what do you
think would happen if the town
increased the or enacted a minimum wage
that is higher than w sub 1. and
actually let's assume a situation where
the town enacts a minimum wage that's
right here at w sub 2. what does the
marginal factor cost curve now look like
for this monopsony employer and now what
would be the rational quantity of labor
to employ pause this video and think
about it
well in a world where the government
sets a minimum wage well then it starts
to feel at least graphically a lot more
like a competitive labor market although
this isn't due to market forces this is
due to just some type of government law
but then the monopsony employer will no
longer have its own supply of labor
curve like this that and it would no
longer have this upward sloping marginal
factor cost curve i'll call this
marginal factor cost curve one
now the government has defined the wage
so no matter how many people they hire
they're going to pay that same wage so
the marginal factor cost is now going to
be a horizontal line at that wage that
the government set so the marginal
factor cost sub 2 and this is due
to a minimum
minimum
wage
now what is the rational quantity to
hire
well like always it's rational to keep
hiring as long as you're on every
incremental unit of labor your marginal
revenue product is higher than your
marginal factor cost so they keep hiring
all the way until this point and so this
is the rational quantity for them to
hire let's call that q sub 2. and we
already know the wage that's the minimum
wage that the government has set
now something very counter-intuitive has
happened now all of a sudden it's
rational for the firm to hire more
people and the reason why i say this
counter-intuitive if i'm just running
some type of a business and all of a
sudden i have to pay higher wages well i
might say well gee i can't afford to pay
as many people so i'm not going i'm i
actually might have to reduce my
employment
and that might be the case if we're
dealing with if we're dealing with other
types of labor markets if i'm not a
monopsony employer but at least
theoretically based on all the
assumptions we've made and we can debate
on how transferable this is to the real
world if you have a monopsony employer
what this did is is this actually caused
the employer to hire more and you might
say why is that
well now the employer is is paying the
same wage regardless of how many people
they hire before every incremental
person they hired every incremental unit
of labor it raised the wage for everyone
and so in some ways or in a very real
way this made it rational for the firm
to hire more now that doesn't mean that
the firm is better off in this situation
it's just splitting the
it's just splitting that marginal
revenue product differently between the
firm and the employers in the old
situation the firm was able to capture
everything above the wage line and below
the marginal revenue product line so the
firm was able to capture all of that
while in this new world the firm is
capturing everything above
the wage line and below the marginal
revenue product line so it is a
different area
but the other thing to keep in mind is i
picked a very particular wage that would
cause this horizontal marginal factor
cost curve to intersect the marginal
revenue product curve right where the
marginal revenue product curve
intersects the supply of labor curve i
could have picked another wage so the
government could have overshot and it
could have said hey we're going to raise
the minimum wage up here to w sub 3 and
then what would happen well then your
marginal
your marginal factor cost curve would be
up here marginal factor cost sub 3 and
the rational quantity to higher would
would actually go down which is a little
bit more intuitive for what would happen
when you enact a minimum wage but at
least theoretically when you're dealing
with a monopsony employer there could be
a situation where forcing the wages up
could cause the employer to hire more
which is counter-intuitive